confrontés à l'inflation comme par tout
ailleurs cette boulangerie paysanne a dû
augmenter ses tarifs en un an plus 2%
sur les brioches le pain aux graines ou
le pain de saison bio mais ici il y a un
produit qui fait encore de la résistance
qui a été produit à la ferme avec noblés
qui sont qui sont cultivés à Broué moulu
à Broué dans notre moulin à meule de
pierre c'est une niche faite avec du
levain les propriétaires ont baissé son
prix d'un euro cette miche est vendue
4,50 €. un effort commercial difficile
mais que les clients apprécient c'est
très bien très bonne initiative les
temps sont dures donc faut que tout le
monde baisse un petit peu ses prix pour
tout le monde puisse bien profiter de
manger on voyait que des clients avaient
des difficultés aussi à revenir pour
certains et nous l'ont exprimé certains
ont décidé de manger moins de pain et
manger des va de nous faire couper des
choses en plus petite quantité et ça
nous est vraiment mal au cœur de de ne
pas pouvoir soutenir
nos clients et voilà donc on a pris
cette décision là pour trois mois dans
la commune l'initiative a eu un effet
boule de neige d'autres producteurs et
commerçants ont eux aussi décidé de
baisser leur prix sur certains de leurs
produits Germain bobion est agriculteur
bio malgré une hausse de 25% de ses
charges il vend désormais moins cher
l'une de ces 10 variétés de pommes de
terre cultivées sur son exploitation on
est sur de la grilla donc une pomme de
terre polyvalente voilà elle sert à
faire un petit peu de tout globalement
la pomme de terre est vendue à peu près
20 à 30 centimes moins cher qu'avant sa
motivation soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
des consommateurs en rendant accessible
des produits de base c'est aussi montrer
qu'on peut quand même du coup accéder à
de la nourriture saine à un prix correct
cet élan de solidarité est prévu
jusqu'au 30 avril le temps pour les
habitants de passer l'hiver plus
sereinement